In 1964 President Johnson, declared a
national War on Poverty. So how we done?
By one metric, not too well. In 1966, when
the last major War on Poverty programs
were coming online, the official census
poverty rate stood at 14.7 percent.
Since then, the government
has spent about 20 trillion dollars on
these programs. And with all this money,
we've only dropped the rate by about one
percentage point, to 13.5 percent. Now, the official poverty rate is
an imperfect measurement. It excludes
some government programs and the modern
comforts that capitalism and innovation
have brought to everyone, up and down the
income distribution. But America wasn't
just trying to make poverty a little
less miserable to endure. We were trying
to make poverty more escapable. If more
Americans had been able to escape
poverty and earn their own success, we
would see a lot more progress in the
official poverty rate. That's why the War
on Poverty has been a moral failure. We
need to make poverty not just easier to
bear, but easier to escape.
To learn more about how to help Americans escape poverty, check the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you want AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.